working in Africa I'm very conscious
that there are 53 countries and that
they are moving at different speeds and
that you also have important pan-african
and regional African institutions there
was a reform of the African Union and it
has a commission like the commission of
the european union half the members of
that Commission are women so there's a
big commitment to gender in a lot of
issues in many of the countries now
there is a real sense that things are
moving forward and there was a recent
Pew opinion sampling taken and most of
the African country sampled really felt
there's a lot of room for improvement
but we're on the right Road commitment
to the Millennium Goals and better
government's tackling corruption so I
think there's a tendency sometimes to
sort of right off Africa in a sweep as
being a basket case or something far
from it they're actually very
interesting and very progressive things
happening in many of the countries in
Africa
you